foreign
[Music]
hey there I'm Cameron and welcome to
stylecraft this is a bonus video for you
so this video uh is what you see on
screen here it's something where I made
I took advantage of repetition which
we've learned about in previous weeks
and I created this 3D box thing I call
it uh stacking boxes and I just want to
show you guys really quickly how I made
this
um and this I'm going to break down a
little bit differently I'm just going to
show you the project I had and kind of
just step through it and show you how I
actually created this instead of
starting from scratch I'm just going to
kind of work backwards and show you what
was involved in this project so what
you're seeing here is the version I
posted on Instagram
and it's just a loop as you can see here
in my timeline this is a pre-comp that
I've got set up to Loop
um one two three four five times over
the course of almost 10 seconds
and I found that where ends here was a
good looping point to go back here to
the beginning so this is it pretty
simple but it looks pretty cool so let's
go into the pre-comp
and inside the pre-comp it's pretty
simple as well it's a Cinema 4D file
with an adjustment layer and a
background so if I back up and start
with just the background the background
is just solid it's a dark green green
lime solid and a lot of times I like to
work with
blacks that aren't 100 black sometimes I
do work with 100 black or 100 white in
this case it's um in the green spectrum
and it's very dark but if you were to
look
there's 100 black and here's my original
greenish black so that was important
because if this was 100 black it
wouldn't look as good
with these solids back here in my
opinion
so I've got the background and then I've
got this 3D layer that uh if I open it
up in Cinema 4D
is this right here
and just to jump back really quickly
you'll also notice that this composition
is 1080 by 1080 24 frames per second I
have been building compositions at 1080
by 1080 lately because of Instagram and
when I built this I knew I wanted to
post this to Instagram
specifically which is why I built it at
1080 by 1080. so back in cinema
this composition is also 1080 by 1080.
if I click on my settings right here
you'll see that it's 1080 by 1080. it's
also 24 frames per second a total length
of 48 frames which you see down here so
it's two seconds long I also taught you
that in a previous lesson you have to
also change your project settings
instead of a 40 and the project settings
are under edit project settings and it's
changed to 24 frames per second as well
here
so back in After Effects since this is
48 frames long
I kind of played around a little bit and
I found that every 12 frames having this
animation on top of itself uh seemed to
create a perfect Loop for me so this was
just trial and error of I started with
you know zero
like if I was to like line these all up
this didn't Loop very well to create
this kind of stacking box effect
um I could have deleted some of these
layers and had like you know just
three here going
but I found that uh
was this total one two three four at a
time looked a little bit uh more
interesting to me so that's why these
are stacked every 12 frames
back in cinema
really simply here all I did is I
created a cube which is under create
object Cube or you can click right here
and create a cube
and if I do that
you'll also see that the cube here has a
fillet
enabled and it has a radius of 25 and a
subdivision of 25 this is kind of just
personal taste so if I turn the original
off
go back to the one I just created by
default fillet is or maybe it's fill it
I have a tendency to pronounce words
wrong A lot of times so I think it is
fill it actually so if I click fill it
you can see here that's what it looks
like
but to get the dimensions right I also
did 500 by 50 by 500 so
let's go back and here it defaults to
200 by 200 by 200 so let's go 500.
by 50.
by 500.
there we go
so that's just a cube fill it turned on
it makes these kind of curved edges it
defaults to 25. I did play around with
some different numbers here
I think 25 is as high as it goes maybe
um but 25 worked
and you'll notice when I change it from
five
if you watch right in here you'll see it
smooth out just a little bit so 25 right
in here
Smooths out just slightly so that worked
for me as well
and I believe that was all I do with the
cube
so the next thing I did was I created a
new material that I dropped on this Cube
super simple it's one material here it
is all I did to create this material was
I went to create
load material preset broadcast materials
[Music]
abstract two sides blue and green
there it is so that was the material
I then
[Music]
um
kind of tweaked it slightly as you can
see here here's the original one I used
and I believe what I did was
it was color
and
transparency here I think I just changed
the color I changed it to more of a red
which you know based on the final image
there's some color correction here you
can see the red going on
um but you know if I was to stick with
the original just straight up blue and
green that's pretty cool as well I'm
gonna go ahead and turn on interactive
render region
and that's what that looks like
so that's just as cool in my opinion
I've also got just to show you a simple
light in the scene so this is without
the light okay just if you were just to
have this box drop the material on
that's what it looks like and it's not
as interesting right but by adding a
light
foreign
that creates a lot more interesting
highlights and specular information here
and along the edge here which makes it
that much more interesting to look at
so all this is
it is an area light which I tend to use
quite a bit of
um
default to 100 percent
it's 100 white I think these are all
defaults so to create the area light if
I was to turn that guy off
is just go up here to light
or create as well light
and you've got light spotlight Target
light area light a few different lights
um some of these are going to show up in
your version if you're on Cinema 40
light
but uh area light is there
so there it is I just raised it up here
and then I just rotated it I don't think
you even have to rotate I always seem to
think that you know the light has to
face the object but that's the same look
as with it well it's slightly different
so there's a dark line so
rotate the light it's essentially just a
big square that just lights your scene
right so if I jump out of here
there's the top view and there's my
Square I can actually
drag the sides out
like so and make it a much bigger light
and it does change the look of you know
my scene here it's a much a lot more
highlight specular going on on the
image on the Block
so go back to how it was there it is
and at this point all I had to do then
was just animate my Cube moving up right
and that's just under coordinates I set
a keyframe for y
I drag it down somewhere in here
clicked there's a keyframe I went to the
end of my timeline and because the light
was sitting right here
I just drug the cube right below the
light and that gives the illusion
because it's so close to light it's not
being lit
or you can barely see it so it almost
looks like it kind of Fades out right
so if I play this
there's my animation
and I talked about this in the week that
we talked about form where you can right
click on this Animation Show F curve uh
Cinema 40 defaults to the spleen with
the keyframes and I just want this to be
linear because I am looping it and I
just wanted a constant motion right of
the boxes
we go back to that Loop
I mean you see here the boxes they're
not starting slow and moving up and
slowing down it's just a constant rate
of speed right so I want that in Cinema
4D so I just highlight both keys and I
click on linear right here
so if I play it now
just a linear move from bottom to top
the last thing I had to do
was add a tag which we've talked about
in
one of the lessons this week actually
adding we talked about adding an
external compositing tag well this time
all I'm doing to this Cube
is I am adding
a Cinema 4D tag display
and what a display tag does is if I
click on these I can turn these on and
I'm going to turn on visibility that's
about the only one I ever really do much
with sometimes I do use enhanced opengl
but most time it's visibility and this
is just like a fade in and out so I can
set this to zero
you can't see it I can set a keyframe
and then I can move forward in my
timeline
to maybe somewhere in here and say at
this point it's 100 percent
opaque and I set another keyframe
and what I found I don't know if there's
a workaround there's probably a work
around this but because there is a
display tag here
when we're working in the viewport at
least with the Cinema 4D basic renderer
you can't see the object until the first
frame passed a zero value which is kind
of strange but if I render this like
you're seeing here it's not on
it's starting to fade on
depending on more and then here it is at
100
and then I think I went a couple of keys
uh forward and I set another keyframe at
zero 100 and then went to the end and
said okay we're back to zero
and
by doing those very few simple things I
got my default
uh render which was this guy right here
if I render this out
so here he is fading in and that light's
sitting right there so it kind of looks
like it's fading out but it's fading out
and it's also the Light it's getting so
close to the light that is getting
darker at the same time
and then I went in and I changed it to
add so that there was some transparency
then I looped these so they're every 12
frames and that's what it looks like
here if I change these back to normal
it's not quite as interesting
there's the normal mode
I was cool but with ADD much more
interesting
and then the very last step in After
Effects is I created a new adjustment
layer and I added some effects
and those effects are right here
of course I started with my chroma warp
subtle warp very subtle effect you can
you know see it mostly on the edges here
so I turned that on I did a very soft
glow which is right here in the middle
I also added some noise from After
Effects this is built-in noise it's a
set to five percent noise very low value
so off on
you probably can't even see it on the
screen that you're watching but without
and with you can really see in the edges
over in here and here and then the final
effect I added was a third-party plug-in
that I used quite a bit of it's called a
fresh lift curves and it's um it's a
curves plug-in that's just very powerful
to use I've used this guy for years I
can't remember how much this guy costs I
don't remember it being very cheap but
it's worth it for the power of editing
curves inside of After Effects so I
added that and it's a very subtle effect
here as well just boosting up some of
the the darkness of the shot which I
tend to produce shots that are very dark
and I a lot of times have to boost the
levels well you could have easily done
this with the curves that's built into
after effects and in fact the newer
version of After Effects has some really
powerful curves adjustments built into
to the Luma tree color correction plugin
so that's definitely worth checking out
it's very cool Power in the curves plug
in there so that's it that's how I
created this
pretty cool loop here
turn this back on and just show you one
more time that's my stacked boxes Loop
that I posted up on Instagram
um
simple workflow I put it together pretty
quickly Sometimes the best work that
people respond to is the stuff that just
gets thrown together very quickly and
you don't have to think a lot about it
sometimes like me personally I over tend
to overthink my designs and by the time
I've reworked them and reworked them
they're not as interesting anymore so
glad you guys found this one cool and
hopefully you got something out of this
little bonus video about how I used
repetition to create stacking boxes
that's all I got for you today
talk to you real soon see you guys bye